when you got to match up with another  big he's just not accustomed to that  [Applause]  shot clock didn't reset to the fluoride  here come the Ducks if Wisconsin can't  flatten Pritchett out and keep from  penetrating it's one and he's telling  him about it you want to talk do you let  you play do your talking keep quiet  thankfully for the Badgers looks like  happens okay Badgers have missed four  straight shots part that I have a  quibble with those lately  drove it open three where they  desperately needed add wait there's  another offensive rebound  [Applause]  this I'm talking about here comes  Richardson this time and he did on this  one that's what he did that's the way  you do it and look at the Ducks getting  out and running and there's Prichard  easy bucket the Ducks are up as well see  you later